c'est motivé pour les motiver les petits
gars des pièces qui vous donne à l'île
maurice pour que vous revenez dans cet
état là il me promettent de patin de
photo est celle d'un contrat bien moi je
voyage avec une moche on me fout la paix
est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez de vous déguiser en
elton john oui est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à reprendre les dix kilos
que vous avez perdu
oui est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à tourner dans un film
pornographique hockey ou d'autres
voulaient bien d'abord est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher le corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient
de tuer parce que par amour vous seriez
prête à devenir scientologues
philippe se convertit à la scientologie
comme tom cruise
attention comme tom cruise son tour
comme travolta dans son petit stade vous
l'épousé pas bien est-ce que paramo vous
seriez prête à vous installer à limoges
oui mais tes filets
tu sors et maintenant messieurs voici
voici la question non pas du tout va si
la question de clotilde courau oui voilà
mon ou ça y est vrai d'embrasser cent
fois les chaussettes sales comme
clotilde courau way est ce qu
apparemment vous soyez prêtes à faire
six enfants
est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez qu'il est une des 13 si
vous l'aimez
calme-toi thierry pour se rapprocher
pour sa paroisse st oui mais par amour
et je vis a raison ohlala il est où ce
philippe convois convoi caillassant
catherine c'est pas fini on va voir tout
de suite si tu es le meilleur
productrice de paris catherine barma
philippe doit venir se montrer parce que
quand une fille et presse à gaza
ok
maintenant tu disais ça
bobby
n c'est une petite mort mais toi
l'infini parce qu ils avaient branché
son arme en avant la vie située à un
tupolev et maintenant quand tu te casses
ou en fait l'un des siens
pour que le sait
jeudi un masque par amour tu accepterais
qu'elle a un amant super peur de
décevoir
j'ai vu en loge la façon de parler moi
je sais moi même dit elles ont même dit
qu'elle était prête à ce que tu es une
maîtresse mais ça je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit pas que pour la téléco à dakar
en tous les cas donc je vous présente
les dames messieurs gilles lellouche
technomedia on l'applaudît
bravo nous donc il va rester jusqu'à la
fin de ce que la lassitude est ya deux
trois questions
c'est à dire que tu sois là philippe je
suivre gérard darmon
merci mes bons amis il ya des moments où
il faut bon est ce que je me suis donné
une anecdote série très très drôle
les parents de gérard cavaillé à
savigny-sur-orge juste en face de chez
mes parents
tu sais ça parce que tes potes alors
vous êtes connu petit nom
dakar alors est-ce que par amour vous
êtes prête à vivre à trois avec la
maîtresse de philippe et maintenant même
les cieux c'est une question importante
parce que jean-philippe ce que je te dis
rien n'a pas qu'elle est venue et textes
et fans de marie pas exception c'est
grâce à moi alors je les dissuader
certains l'euthanasie mais là
aujourd'hui je pense pas que je vais
dissuader vanessa demouy d'aller plus
loin
vial alors est-ce que par amour vanessa
demouy vous êtes prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle
oh
oui puisqu'on est dans une période où on
est et où vous avez déjà couché vous
avez raison monsieur a déjà couché avec
une fille non à mon avis comment pas on
n'est pas surpris
l'une d'elles à mourir